hi everybody i'm william and today i'm
talking to you about pseudorandomness
right so a pseudorandom generator
is a function that stretches a short
truly random seed out to a long
pseudorandom string and and the way we
make this pseudorandomness condition
precise
is that we we consider some class of
functions this the script f
and we require that
that this that the output of this
generator looks random to every function
in that class okay so the acceptance
probability of a function in that class
should be approximately the same whether
we're plugging in truly random bits or
pseudorandom bits
and maybe the most traditional setting
would be if we take this this class
script app to be like everything that
can be computed in polynomial time or
something like that
but for today actually we're more
interested in the case that this class
script f is like very restricted
and
the benefit of looking at a very
restricted class of functions is that
then we can actually prove something we
can design pseudorandom generators that
provably work so like maybe the simplest
possible example uh here's a
pseudorandom generator that stretches
two bits out to three bits
right but the class of functions that
we're going to fool are just uh depth
two decision trees on these three bits
so you know a little toy model and the
generator says you take these two
the two bits of the seed x and y and
then you output x and then y and then
the xor of x and y right this is like
the classic example of a distribution
that's pairwise independent which means
in particular that it will fool these
depth two decision trees things that
only look at two bits
so that's just like a very simple you
know toy examples you know trying to
illustrate uh this concept and that it
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
like a conditional thing where we make
complexity theoretic assumptions or
anything like that we can make you know
concrete constructions of pseudorandom
generators that that work for for simple
sort of combinatorial reasons
potentially
um
but of course you know we're really more
interested in in uh classes f that are
maybe a little more rich than something
you know
overly simplistic like this and so
for example um just to give you some
examples of my research on this topic
with collaborators
um so we've we've designed like explicit
pseudorandom generators for uh
restricted models of computation like
read once bounded depth circuits
or
bounded depth threshold circuits
or certain kinds of
branching programs things like this and
so when you restrict the model then you
know hopefully we get these models of
computation there that are hopefully
still interesting they're rich enough to
do something something interesting uh
but they're weak enough that we can
actually fool them
so let me try to give you some some
motivation for for why would we why
would be interested in uh theorems like
the ones that i had on the previous
slide you know why design pseudorandom
generators for these models
well the most basic reason to design a
pseudorandom generator is to try to
decrease the number of random bits that
you're using for some computational
process
okay right because if you're using a
pseudorandom generator
now the only random bits that we need
are the seed of that generator
okay and so we want to think of random
bits as being like a scarce
computational resource just like time or
space so just like a faster algorithm is
better than a slower algorithm
we want to think of an algorithm that
uses fewer random bits as being better
than an algorithm that uses more random
bits
and best of all is an algorithm that
doesn't use any randomness right a
deterministic algorithm and that's also
sometimes i mean depending on the
context that might be something that you
can achieve with a pseudorandom
generator because
to try to you know to get rid of this
last little bit of randomness the seed
of the generator uh we can potent i mean
depending on the context we can
potentially
just try all seeds and see what happens
you know for every single one of those
seeds
another reason to design pseudorandom
generators is that actually uh sometimes
they're useful uh for the for designing
randomized algorithms
um just you know in some contexts uh uh
this comes up like streaming algorithms
is maybe a classic
example so that's so that seems a little
bit like the opposite of the previous
goals but yeah
and and and maybe actually the most
important reason is a little bit subtler
uh which is just that when we design a
pseudorandom generator for some class of
functions f if we're able to design an
unconditional generator you know a
construction that we can truly just
write down and analyze
then that really sheds a lot of light on
this class f it teaches us something
about this model of computation
so you can think of a pseudo-random
generator as like a highly refined type
of lower bound for this model it's
giving like an example of a task that
this model of computation cannot solve
at all it doesn't understand it at all
right because the pseudorandom generator
is sampling some distribution that's
actually you know a very low entropy
distribution but it looks totally random
to this class f so it's like the class f
has you know no understanding of the
structure that is actually
present um so just to give you some idea
of like what sort of problems there are
to work on in this area
um really one of the biggest uh open
problems is to try to design uh better
pseudorandom generators for space
bounded computation this this problem uh
drives and motivates like a lot of the
research in this area
um
maybe some potentially easier problems
hopefully easier problems would be like
even even for simple models of
computation like read once cns okay so
this is an and of ors of variables and
each variable only happens one time okay
or literals i should say you know we
allow not gates also and even for that
like very simple model of computation we
still don't have optimal pseudorandom
generators we have very close to optimal
but we're not quite there yet um
and then there are also you know
interesting you know other you know
somewhere in the middle there are
interesting models of like founded depth
uh read once circuits of various types
where we can hope to design very good
pseudorandom generators and right now we
only have pretty good superheated
generators
okay so so let me slightly move on to it
you know very related topic which is
deer randomization it already came up
one time right one of the
reasons to design pseudorandom
generators is to try to de-randomize
algorithms which i think is is a
also just you know a nice goal in its
own right
um
so as a reminder
this class bp space s
is the class of languages that can be
decided by a randomized algorithm that
uses of s bits of space
and the conjecture the popular
conjecture says that bp space s
coincides with deterministic space s
right so this conjecture is saying that
randomness is not actually necessary for
space efficient computation so you know
you might as well take all your fair
coins and throw them in the trash can
um and so if you've ever studied you
know complexity theory at all uh you
know that there are a lot of conjectures
like this you know we have all sorts of
ideas but what we think is true about uh
the relationships between you know
different fundamental uh computational
resources like in this case space and
randomness um
and in most cases these problems are you
know really extremely difficult and and
you know people have been working on
them for a long time with very little
success one thing that sets this problem
apart a little bit is that i i would
argue that there's more hope of actually
proving this compared to you know some
of the other similar uh you know
superficially similar similar
conjectures in complexity theory
um and one piece of evidence for that
you know one reason to maybe have some
hope about this problem is that we do
have uh quite a few partial results so
i'll just mention a couple partial
results that you know that are my own
research but but there are plenty of
other examples that i have nothing to do
with
um
so one would be uh you know we can at
least say all right if we have vp space
s we can de-randomize that with all
right there's some blow up in space but
we can bound the you know the extent to
which the space complexity blows up
and and yes apparently the best bound is
is s to the three halves over square
root log s which is just this you know
this this tiny improvement over uh you
know an older result from the 90s
they've got this best of the three
halves found
or just you know one one more example
would be uh if we if we restrict the
class a little more so we we're not
looking at uh just bounding space but
let's bounce time and space so let's
look at um
problems that can be decided by
randomized algorithms that
simultaneously use quasi-linear time and
logarithmic space
okay then it turns out it's possible to
de-randomize those in log space the
deterministic algorithm is no longer
fast but
uh and then there's this extra caveat
which is that it's only like a typically
correct algorithm
it gives the wrong answer sometimes but
okay so just to wrap up um
i just want to say i mean i don't think
we have really any excuse for having not
yet you know proven uh unconditionally
that vp space s equals deterministic
space s so i'd love to work on this
problem with with any of you
um and let me mention just quickly you
know a couple of problems that are
potentially easier on the way that i
think are fascinating would be like
proving that bpl is contained in nl or
maybe proving that rl is closed under
complement
but anyway thanks for listening and i'd
be happy to answer a question
you